bevor wenn die geschäftsordnung in die
tagesordnung eintreten müssen wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag behandeln die
fraktion der afg hat beantragt den
einzelplan 0 1 zum hauser des
bundespräsidenten mit einer debatten
dauer von 60 minuten zu beraten
zu diesem antrag erteile ich das wurde
den abgeordneten baumann bernd baumann
für die ft begründet jetzt diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer seiner
fraktion aus aktuellem anlass beantragt
die fdp fraktion geschlossen
die vereinbarte tagesordnung zu ändern
grundlage ist § 20 der geschäftsordnung
es geht um folgendes das parlament wird
in dieser woche den etat des
bundespräsidenten einbringen
traditionell geschieht das ohne debatte
das drückt den tiefen respekt des
parlaments vor dem höchsten amt im
staate aus und das ist auch gut so
was uns was uns heute aber veranlasst
davon abzuweichen ist gerade dieser
größter respekt vor dem amt des
bundespräsidenten genauer es ist die
brennende sorge dass das amt schaden
leidet durch einseitige parteinahme des
amtsinhabers meine damen und herren
in solchen schaden vermeidet man nicht
wenn das parlament dazu schweigt ganz im
gegenteil meine damen und herren wir
müssen darüber reden man muss sich
diesmal vor augen führen
der bundespräsident wird für eine
linksradikale großveranstaltung in
chemnitz und 565.000 menschen folgen
diesem lockruf wissen sie eigentlich was
da los war
das lässt sich nur schwer in
parlamentarischer sprache ausdrücken von
der großbühne hämmerten sänger in die
menschenmenge die 65.000 wie gern sie
hören sie doch zu sind ja teilweise ihre
leute wie gern sie busfahrer
zusammenschlagen die köpfe ihrer gegner
vertreten wie gern sie frauen so brutal
vergewaltigen dass sie wörtlich grün und
blau sind ist das mit der höchsten würde
und des höchsten amt im staate vereinbar
wir glauben nicht und deshalb muss die
debatte und die änderung der
tagesordnung hier geführt werden meine
damen und herren
denn natürlich müssen wir darüber reden
dass der bundespräsident persönlich eine
veranstaltung empfiehlt auf der sänger
grünen wie gerne sie wörtlich
messerklingen in journalisten fressen
rahmen wie gern sie sich an brennenden
deutschlandfahnen wärmen und christliche
bibel ins feuer hinterher werfen
wie gerne sie hören sie doch zu frau
göring-eckardt wie gerne sie schwangere
frauen in den bauch treten und sich dann
an der fehlgeburt vergehen das ist so
gewalt verherrlichen das ist so deutsch
feindlich das ist so christen feindlich
wenn ein amtsinhaber seine
neutralitätspflicht so offensichtlich
verletzt dann muss hier seinen etat
gegenstand der debatte werden
meine damen und herren aus respekt vor
dem amt des bundespräsidenten müssen wir
jetzt vor den fehlgriffen frank walter
steinmeier schützen
wir sind mehr unter diesem motto verlief
die veranstaltung in chemnitz und einer
gruppe namens feine sahne fischfilet hat
dort gespielt das hatte auch schon teile
der union kritisiert dass dort der
bundespräsident zu diesem konzert
aufgerufen hat nun michael grosse brömer
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zunächst einmal ist es wie immer mit den
afd anträgen sie kriegen es nicht seriös
ja sie wollen doch wenn ich direkt die
verstand haben eine extra debatte zum
einzelplan des bundespräsidenten war
schreiben sie in ihrem antrag aussetzung
des haushalts für die bundestags
präsidentin gut ist waren fünf sätze es
waren fünf sätze davon ist der
hauptstadt schon mal falsch aber das ist
eben ihr problem mit seriöser
parlamentarische arbeit dann stützen sie
lesen sie nach lesen sie nach morgen sie
nicht schütteln den kopf steht in ihrem
antrag dann stützte den antrag auf
paragraf 79 der geschäftsordnung nicht
auf § 20 das war gerade neu in ihrem
vortrag dieser sache vereinfacht zu den
gesetzentwürfen in erster lesung sondern
warte stattfinden wenn eine fraktion ist
verlangt klar
aber jetzt mal ehrlich haben sie die
tagesordnung die wir gemeinsam
vereinbart haben zu dieser woche
überhaupt gelesen es gibt es gibt ja ich
habe ja gar kein problem mit notwendigen
änderungen aber das worum es sich hier
handelt um diesen haushalts
gesetzentwurf reden wir von heute morgen
bis freitagnachmittag es gibt nie mehr
debatten zeit als für dieses gesetz hier
und sie können jederzeit das ansprechen
was sie wollen dann brauchen sie keine
geänderte tagesordnung das was sie stört
können sie jetzt über vier tage jeden
tag ansprechen an der änderung der
tagesordnung ist überhaupt nicht
erforderlich
und jetzt gibt es natürlich gibt es die
parlamentarische tradition nicht nur
beim bundespräsidenten das gilt auch für
den fan des bundesverfassungsgerichts
des bundesrates des bundestages
überhaupt weil man nämlich an anderer
stelle ausführlich dazu arbeiten kann
also es ist niemand gehindert das zu
sagen was er will in dieser
haushaltsdebatte dafür bedarf es keiner
änderungen ihr antrag ist wiedermal
handwerk die stümperhaft und in der
sache unsinn
aber sie haben ja auch gerade gezeigt es
geht in erster linie ja nicht um
parlamentarische abläufe sondern um
chemnitz wo eine schreckliche straftat
stattgefunden hat die aufgeklärt werden
muss die täter müssen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden und die cdu/csu und ich
denke auch viele andere haben vertrauen
in polizei und justiz damit dass auch
vonstatten geht und die power die trauer
zu diesem vorfall ist verständlich und
berechtigt aber ihnen geht es nach
meiner einschätzung jedenfalls nicht in
erster linie um aufklärung und trauer
hin geht es um die spaltung der
gesellschaft und das immer wieder und
auch hier im parlament das was wir an
hassreden mussten den chemnitzern
rechtsextremen parolen und hitler grüßen
das ist nicht chemnitz das ist auch
nicht sachsen das ist auch nicht
deutschland das sind vor allen dingen
ihresgleichen ihre funktionäre die ganz
bewusst die grenze zum rechtsextremismus
einreißen das ist die wahrheit
sie haben ihre eigenen funktionären
nicht mehr unter kontrolle wenn die auf
die straße gehen und schon gar nicht
mehr die notwendige distanz zu den
neonazis die damit laufen und ich sage
ich man marschiert nicht an der seite
der rechtsextremismus man bekämpft ihn
bei der damen und herren
man bekämpft ging dann bekämpft ihn
übrigens auch nicht mit linksextremisten
besonnen mit demokratie menschlichkeit
und anstand das ist die richtige antwort
auf rechtsextreme tendenzen in
deutschland abschließen abschließend
noch ein satz der bundespräsident
richard von weizsäcker hat mal gesagt
patriotismus ist liebe zu den seinen
nationalismus ist hass auf andere seit
chemnitz steht für mich fest patrioten
sind sie nicht
frauen werden
weitere wortmeldungen liegen mir nicht
vor
damit kommen wir zur abstimmung über den
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf aussprache
zu einzelplan 01 wer stimmt dafür
es stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich dann
ist der antrag mit den stimmen der afg
gegen die stimmen der übrigen fraktionen
abgelehnt